derweil diskutiert deutschland nämlich
wissen sie ob der verfassungsschutz
seine ehemalige behörde die afd
beobachten sollte große diskussion
ich meine nein wirklich erstens wegen
opfermythos und zweitens überwacht die
afg sich doch neuerdings selber jetzt
kein witz die haben einen gutachten
erstellen lassen um herauszufinden wie
genau sie eine beobachtung vermeiden
könnten also so eine art extremismus
tests wie könnte man das erklären es ist
in jedem fall eine super idee
es ist eine super idee einfach nicht
mehr zu nutzen
ein gutachten
und in dem gutachten steht dann zum
beispiel drin können sie nachlesen
können sie googeln was für worte man als
achter in zukunft besser vermeiden
sollte das kam riesig an bei der basis
wenn wir jetzt all das nicht mehr sagen
dürfen was was was mir auch wichtig ist
und was eben auch unsere marke ist dann
sind wir nicht anders als irgendein
anderer partei dann braucht sie uns gern
gesperrt dann sind wir überflüssig wenn
sie selber sagt hoppmann
ich kann die frau schon verstehen jetzt
hat die afd auch noch eine eigene
sprachpolizei so weit sind wir schon in
deutschland rechte gegen rechts das kann
doch alles nicht wahr sein und über
welches problem reden wir hier
eigentlich jörg merten und seine leute
halten sich doch längst an sämtliche
spielregeln
wir sollten uns von einer wortwahl
fernhalten die eine kriminalisierung
aller migranten enthielt papa gefährde
mama gefährde und die gefährder bambini
ja natürlich weil nicht alle migranten
kriminell sind und wer das wissen
masseneinwanderung es messen wanderung
deswegen ist das für uns auch keine
wortwahl die in unserer partei von
irgendjemand ergriffen wird seit der
massenschlägerei vergewaltigung das darf
nicht sein wird nicht sein
die gipfel eingehen natürlich zum
staatlichen werteunterricht und
hinterher zu papas enthauptung
unterricht das aber eine
selbstverständlichkeit eine
selbstverständlichkeit meine damen und
herren eine selbstverständlichkeit und
auf einer art ist es natürlich auch
schön dass die afg jetzt quasi
schriftlich hat wie sie sich einer
beobachtung entziehen kann
matthias matschke leitet die afa
ortsgruppe in köln-mülheim wir schalten
wir live rüber in sein wohnzimmer sehr
fröhliche runde herr manche arbeiten sie
schon mit dem neuen afg gutachten ja
klar deswegen treffen wir uns ja also
heute ist bei mir zuhause quasi
volkshochschule
früher sagte man völkische hochschule
[Gelächter]
so ja leute ich habe hier das gutachten
hier heißt es zur vermeidung einer
beobachtung gilt es unbedingt folgendes
zu beachten
ja klaus da hat das noch lange ich habe
gerade für ein rechtsrock konzert ja
doch gerade erst angefangen kann ja wohl
nicht wahr sein so bitte zu hören
unbedingt zu unterlassen sind zitat
pauschale diffamierung oder
herabwürdigung von ausländern
immigranten flüchtlingen muslimen punkt
wer sowas macht kann bei uns nicht mehr
mitmachen
leute leute leuten ist das was ist
selbst noch mal gefährliche leute sechs
einfach heute wieder gegen setzt sich
wieder hin
[Musik]
ok
weiter im text die religionsfreiheit der
in deutschland lebenden muslime darf
nicht in frage gestellt werden ganz
wichtig klaus was ist mit kernmarke
[ __ ] ist auch keine religion klaus
manchmal frage ich mich wirklich so
ebenfalls bitte vermeiden extremistisch
reizwörter wie umvolkung überfremdung
volkstod oder umerziehung mir alles
nicht mehr sagen okay dann ja dann haut
er war da geht auch spd vize npd weil es
natürlich spaß
john slade was sich jetzt ja blöd dass
er jetzt geht ich hatte nämlich für alle
negerkuss brötchen gemacht so bitte auch
nicht mehr sagen das wort lügen presse
okay kein problem kein problem geht
ruhig dafür ist mein aus verband jetzt
sauber ich verleihe mir das prädikat
offiziell extremisten frei so ich bin zu
spät habe ich was verpasst
[Applaus]
er setzt sich hin wenn jeder kurs
bluechips matthias steffan filtern
[Applaus]
[Musik]